Then mention new content.
And you've learned how
to publish your apps.
But you may be wondering,
what should I learn next?
At this point, you're prepared to
take most of our Android courses.
But I want to draw your
attention to two in particular.
Our Gradle course, Gradle for Android
and Java, is a great look at the build
system we've been using
alongside Android Studio.
In that class, you learn the magic
behind the Android build process.
And customize your build by creating
multiple app flavors, incorporating
external libraries and tools, and
adding units and integration tests.
The other course you're now ready for,
is our performance course,
featuring a lot more cult.
Performance is vital if you want to make
that move smoothly on older devices.
And get a more global audience for
your app.
I've added links to each class in
the instructor notes below the video.
Take some time to build the final
project for this class first.
And then choose a direction.
We can't wait to see what you'll build.